[Music]
conservatives should care about the 2022
decennial census for one it's mandated
in the US Constitution and right up top
fidelity to the Constitution implies
fidelity to a fair and accurate census
in addition the census is critical to
American business the best way for a
free market to work efficiently and
fairly is for businesses of every size
to have access to accurate information
to help them make critical decisions if
conservatives want businesses to make
the best decisions possible they should
want a fair and accurate census a major
threat to the accuracy of the census is
underfunding why due to rhetoric coming
from Washington members of some
immigrant and minority communities have
already shown concern about answering
census questions the commerce
secretaries unfortunate decision to
include a citizenship question makes
matters worse the more reluctant people
are to answer the survey the more money
census will have to spend to get their
answers in addition since this is
employing new technologies for the 2020
count that will save taxpayers money in
the long run but those technologies need
to be tested and protected against
threats an accurate census is in all our
interests Congress needs to step up what
do you think about the 2020 census and a
citizenship question let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI